we've reviewed the polling right earlier
in the show we looked at the polling
clearly this is a close race the deep
that as a result the presidential
debates are expected to number one get
Super Bowl level viewership starting
with the first debate tonight and number
two potentially could really really
impact the race which they should the
first debate if you haven't heard is
tonight 9 p.m. eastern time 6 p.m.
pacific uh it is at Hofstra University
in Hempstead New York the moderator is
Lester Holt probably Lester Holt's
biggest night in journalism and media of
his life the debate topics are going to
include America's direction achieving
prosperity and securing America who is
debating because we we do have more than
just Donald Trump and Hillary Clinton
but no Libertarian candidate Gary
Johnson and green party candidate Jill
Stein who would love to be on that stage
are not going to be there you need uh at
least fifteen percent support in
national polling I believe that they
take five recent polls and take the
average there neither gary johnson or
Jill Stein or even remotely close to
that so they will not be on the stage
tonight the format we will have 6 15
minute segments each segment we'll start
with a question the candidates will get
two minutes to respond followed by
responses to each other and then the
remaining time is going to be for quote
deeper discussion that is exactly what I
want to focus on with you today can
Donald Trump engage in deeper discussion
can he faked his way through suppose a
deep discussion on any important
political topic uh Lonnie Chen is a
research fellow at the Hoover
Institution who worked for romney and
Marco Rubio and he said on CNN's party
people podcast a few days ago that no
Donald Trump cannot fake his way through
90 minutes of deep discussion debate
here is a quote from Lonnie Chen
lunchy Jen uh the 90-minute general
election format makes it a lot harder to
one line your way through it I think
it's going to be very very hard for
Donald Trump to spend 90 minutes bumper
sticker in I think he's got to have
something as I watch tonight's debate
I'm going to try to make a list of the
actual positions that Trump and Clinton
respectively take I'm going to make a
list of the ideas that they propose so
we can try to eliminate bluster sidebar
insults and really figure out what do
the candidates know and can they go one
talking point deep on an issue can they
go to talking points deep on an issue
could they go three could they actually
uh elicit up from each other because I
think that's what what's going to take I
don't know that Lester Holt is going to
elicit deeper discussion from Donald
Trump necessarily maybe from Hillary
Clinton I'm not sure can they really put
each other in positions to have to
demonstrate that they know something and
and that's how I'm going to watch this
thing here's the problem for Hillary
Clinton there is no doubt that Hillary
Clinton is exponentially infinitely
overwhelmingly more competent
knowledgeable and qualified than Donald
Trump on essentially every political
issue but can she make that clear within
the bounds of the debate format without
seeming number one boring and I know
it's sad it's sad that I have to say
Hillary can't be boring because that is
a really big factor in how the debate
tonight will be perceived and number two
not being overly wonky there was an
interesting article i read this morning
and i read so much this morning to get
caught up on what's going on it was
either New York magazine I i think it
was New York Magazine about and the gist
of it was Hillary Clinton's wonkiness
may actually not serve her that well and
uh I I'm curious to see how she presents
her clearly deep knowledge of many
issues in the debate tonight and now I I
do want to warn those who are or
emailing me daily and saying David first
debates gonna happen Trump's gonna make
a fool out of himself because you
can't fake your way through something
like this it is actually possible to
sort of fake your way through a
90-minute debate let's take an example
in thinking back to the two thousand
eight election the vice presidential
debate between vice presidential nominee
Sarah Palin and vice presidential
nominee Joe Biden Sarah Palin was
embarrassingly clueless compared to Joe
Biden and in the instant poles that were
done after the debate yes Biden did win
but it wasn't this overwhelming as
anyone with a clue would have told you
because number one Sarah Palin memorized
many of what are sort of called disarm
lines lines which no matter what Joe
Biden said she memorized and was was
relatively well coached in knowing how
she can pivot in a way that doesn't make
it obvious that she doesn't know a thing
about the issue and number two she also
was able to memorize some scripted
answers about specific topics now if you
were listening carefully or if you knew
something about the topics you would
recognize all you know Joe Biden said a
and it sounded sort of like Sarah Palin
was refuting a but actually she was just
saying be and it really wasn't any kind
of debate or counter or rebuttal of any
kind but if you're only sort of paying
attention and you're looking at tone and
presence it seemed like hit like Sarah
Palin actually did okay and that could
happen tonight as far as Donald Trump is
concerned uh last issue I want to talk
about here and we've talked about debate
prep before how Hillary Clinton and
Donald Trump respectively have been
prepping for this major debate tonight
there have been some so-called leaks or
slips or whatever from the Trump
campaign uh that Trump is not doing any
formal prep like normal candidates do
he's not doing a full-length mock debate
for example that may be true it may not
be true but these so-called leaks may be
deliberate and we're already seeing both
the Republican and Democratic sort of
surrogates talking heads all day today
lowering expectations the Trump the
Republican people saying listen Hillary
Clinton has the clear advantage she's an
experienced debater Trump is not an
experienced debater etcetera etcetera
and I believe that this whole idea of
how try
is not preparing in the way that most
candidates prepare if Trump does not do
well tonight and probably even if he
does do well you will hear listen the
guy is not an experienced debater he
didn't prepare in the way that most
candidates prepare and he still did ok /
pretty well / incredibly well and that
that is something that can come out no
matter how well or poorly Donald Trump
does tonight I predict as far as how
trumple handle himself uh because a lot
of people are emailing me seeming to
think that it's going to be the super
aggressive Trump I think number one
Trump may surprise people by showing up
and being sort of conciliatory and
respectful and positive and nobody's
going to know how to react and I I'd be
curious to see how the Trump voters
react to that number two I would expect
some Marco Rubio type deflection from
Donald Trump tonight uh on on a number
of different issues and this goes beyond
just scripted disarm statements but
really significant deflection when he's
put on the spot by Hillary Clinton on
very very specific issues this could
come in the form a potentially of
references to Hillary Clinton uh pseudo
scandal so-called scandals etcetera some
have speculated that maybe it would even
involve bringing in Bill Clinton's
personal history into this entire thing
I don't really know but i would
definitely anticipate reflection and
lastly Trump has very successfully taken
the position of the guy who is being
unfairly treated by everybody medias
treating him unfairly the Republican
Party's treating him unfairly
everybody's treating him unfairly and I
would I would expect that there are
going to be some accusations of lack of
fairness tonight in the debate uh last
thing I want to mention research more
in-depth if you have a few minutes
before the debate tonight something
called the Gish gallop I'll put up a
definition of the Gish gallop from
rational wiki for you this is something
I've talked about before the gift gallop
also known as proof by verbosity is the
fallacious debating tactic of simply
drowning your opponent in a torrent of
small interlocking arguments intended
to prevent your opponent from being able
to rebut your conclusions in real time
the dish gallop is thus essentially a
belt-fed cousin of the on-the-spot
fallacy as it's unreasonable for anyone
to have an answer immediately available
to every single argument presented in
the gala this may be Trump's best
technique going forward you answer with
a talking point you mention the email
scandal you mentioned Benghazi you
mentioned something about Hillary
Clinton who knows what and you basically
run out the clock such that Hillary
Clinton will realistically only be able
to rebut one or maybe two of those ideas
that Trump throws out there the gish
gallop very very common tactic for the
underprepared or uh uh under cognitively
able candidate in debates I will be
watching tonight and tomorrow we will
have full coverage in debriefing Omaha
Steaks sent me a great package of stakes
and it was fantastic as some of the
audience knows my girlfriend is
pescetarian so I invited over some of my
meat-eating friends and we use my new
grill that i finally got now that it's
almost fall and everybody loved it it
was terrific I kind of rather grill in
the fall than summer just less
oppressively hot and the limited time
family grill pack that Omaha Steaks is
offering for just forty nine ninety nine
is a really great way to do it you will
get to filet mignons to top sirloins for
boneless pork chops for chicken fried
steaks a 12 ounce package of all beef
meatballs for omaha steaks burgers for
gourmet jumbo franks a 16 ounce package
of omaha steak house fries for caramel
apple tartlets Omaha Steaks seasoning
and for additional omaha steaks burgers
and just for my listeners Omaha Steaks
is offering all of this for only 49 99
this is a huge savings go to Omaha
Steaks dot-com enter my code Pakman in
the search bar and add the family grill
pack to
your cart do not miss this deal visit
Omaha Steaks dot-com and enter my code
Pakman in the search bar to get over 30
gourmet items for 4999